okay Hermann
Steiner, well, but I
know H5, well, okay, then we
already know what we have to hold V opponents
and knight df6 aha,
well, give me the bishop Bishop D7
okay, yes, okay, that's of course complete
rubbish and you should actually
put it back hard, well, well, black can,
come on, move something in this position.
Doubts here, just queen2 and
develop it further. Yes, he would like to
move E5, but I'll do
E5 myself, especially because the knight on F6
has such incredibly strong squares, e.g.
H7,
so run to bishop  F5 is
unbelievable, so he can hardly afford such a luxury,
so you have to be careful
that you don't
forget
to develop yourself because of all the refutations,
so knight, yes, he can castle for a long time,
a knight F5 and then E6 W
the long wheel
consequences would
probably like bishop F4 with
the ED knight F5 and
yes, long castling is also a
joke, no,
come on, I also have bishop F4
simple and then short castling, e.g.
no
one believes that, okay,
so bishop F4 D wants  He then Wasi I
draw queen F7 or what, well, let
's develop it further H5 is also stuck with
chess
so
stay calm, yes, of course it's
pretty good somehow but it doesn't look
like a direct refutation, admittedly
I
probably should have played differently
yes, the guy doesn't have them
all on the Christmas tree anymore, he could also
just play on the short rochale, I
think that would be
okay now, let's open the box,
so bishop B4 to B1, just like that,
now he can of course take it to c3, that's what he
wants  Let's see if that
isn't a pretty strong attack somehow, with the idea of ​​Bishop
C6,
so both
bishops, I don't think anyone knows, yes, well Knight Knight
D7 could of course
still
do it, although the moment has already
come for bad rook B7 - just a
moment  he has can he can
move knight B6 between them not not too
fast what is bishop C6 bishop
C6 BC C5 threatening Queen
A6 okay BC
C5 a
good now just hangs B7
pointless so let's
see what can you do now
Queen A5
maybe BC is coming  tur
B8 BC tur B8 King D D8 King B7 tur a
check King
A6 King A6
dameck yes come
the
check
check even if I haven't seen it yet
so queen D3 and then queen A3 checkmate
yeah well it was still relatively
clear after that
crazy opening yes
very computer like yes you play but
very very [ __ ]
like
comedian with the king let me know
yes the time is up of course it
's
clear to then file a complaint
it's very funny well well
black forfits on time well there are always weirdos